timor raja both with the white pieces
and in a classical game picking up a
very important three points how are you
feeling
i'm very very happy uh it's very rare
that
you follow a plan from move one and it
just works perfectly so i i took a pawn
and defended it in a very very ugly way
and
that passport won me the game so i'm
very happy with that
let's
visit
some of the details he started taking a
lot of time i think around 14 15
and after the night ec5 you
you said you were optimistic no in the
confessional yeah um
uh it was surprising so uh when you
prepared a bit then surprises are
generally
welcome
uh
i mean it could have been that this move
was in the file but it wasn't one of the
main lines for sure um anyway
i think it's
probably well within
you know
the reach of a draw still
but with each move
that you cannot force the draw
becomes a bit difficult
and um i think i found a good plan with
takes in bishop e3
um and
yeah the idea of
was after bishop f6 to go knight c3
um
and here i was considering some strange
lines like
queen d7 or something but
uh yeah now knight db5 i think is okay
and if knight v3 there's queen d1
um
it could be that rook d1 works as well
the only thing i should avoid is rook d1
um
rook d1 uh no no no not here instead of
knight db5
um
the only thing i should avoid is retakes
on d4 rook d4 then queen b7 i cannot
avoid the um the forks uh but i think i
can take with the bishop on d4 and then
after um
after knight uh b3 there's bishop d7
which i think
i think works
um
[Music]
yeah knight e2 i get an end endgame
opponent
um
anyway uh
yeah so instead but here yeah a bishop
f6 knight c3
um queen b7
queen b1 was my idea
uh and then
again i'm
intending to play knight b5
and uh
these bunched up knights are really
really
potentially really really ugly for for
black maybe there is some concrete
solution but unless unless there isn't i
think having the knight on c3 is better
than
um
than on on d2 so i think he made a good
choice there
at least practically speaking so uh okay
let's move uh a bit forward
um
yeah rookie one
king f1 is really ugly but i it was the
only chance i saw i think if i trade on
c5
he's just too
too too active i really don't want to
give up that bishop if i don't if i
don't have to and i didn't see any other
reasonable plan than putting the rook on
on c1
um
so
here again he had a lot of options but
it's always unpleasant when you have to
calculate a bunch and
the most you can hope for is a draw
anyway
anyway he decided just to make waiting
moves after a long time which to be fair
he could have done immediately uh
like
somebody like napoleon she probably
just made these moves immediately and
then he would have had half an hour more
at the end
but
that's not the way everybody plays
does it influence your decisions when
your opponent is that low on time or you
try to ignore it um
a little bit but in i don't think it did
in this game
anyway yeah 94 uh
i wasn't completely sure but you know it
feels great to exchange a few
few pieces and with every piece
exchanged in general the
d-pawn becomes more and more of a factor
um he did have some tricks here of
course
rk-7 knight t2
but when you
when your opponent puts the queen on d7
you sort of think you might have
you might have a plan because rookie 7
is a bit too too obvious but i think
rook a3 is a
perfectly
decent move
a3 actually
oh it says one before okay oh no no no
no um sorry that was after queen c6
queen c6 then still rook a7 bishop c5
was an idea
sorry
um
but i think their rook a3 instead of
rook a7 was okay
and i don't think he has any tricks so i
think he did okay
um
with
rook a4
knight d5
um
takes and king g2
we were debating queen d3 did you
consider that
yeah
i thought about it but i
um
no i don't know
what's the uh
awesome maybe if i
if he takes
and then rook b said rook b8 and he
didn't think it was anything special
yeah computer is very happy here maxim
said it but yeah but i go with d4
this knight is kind of stuck yeah
oh
okay maybe i missed something there
yeah it could be
anyway what i was happy about here and
what's
also what he talked about after the game
is that his pieces are
basically perfectly placed here and
virtually any move
will worsen his position uh
and
i guess the position is still kind of a
draw but with little time it's really
hard to just sit and wait make waiting
moves so that's why
um yeah queen c6
i thought was okay but then after
[Music]
rook a7 i felt like he should just
return
with the
sorry with the queen
and ask me what my idea is
probably
would go
as as he mentioned after the game some
h4 and then maybe king h2 at some point
maybe queen d3 it's really unpleasant
but it could could hold
um anyway after what he did g5 i don't
think you can say in the game
i mean i thought for
thought for a bit here but i think
this sequence is
is more or less forced i don't think he
can
i mean he has queen before there instead
of
uh
instead of this but then i go rook 8 and
the rook exchange i don't think there
are any chances
um
anyway yeah this b5 was nice of course
uh
if he takes um if he takes knight d4
then
then queenie queen e5 rook d7 queen e4
king g1
um there are no tricks as far as i can
see rook b8 there is for instance uh
knight c2 and uh
he just has nothing
um
oops
yeah rook a8 queen b2 as well or rook
there is just nothing for black there
you looked upset when the game was over
do you were you angry you missed
something or did we just read it wrong
i think you read it completely wrong i
was very happy
different facial expressions
um
[Music]
so the big question as usual are you
staying up tonight to watch basketball
or is that unprofessional oh no way um
i mean i've done that before but three
it's just a bit too late
i'll i'll watch this i'll watch the game
first thing in the morning not gonna
check any
not gonna check my phone nothing just
gonna
just gonna spend the first two and a
half hours of my day watching the game
sounds like a plan thank you so much for
joining us and enjoy thank you